i want to say happy belated birthday
27's never looked so gorgeous
what did morgan get for your birthday
did he nail it we are not gift people
um we're like quality time people so he
had he planned this really sweet like
little staycation date night for us
and it he booked us into this restaurant
that you have the book a long time in
advance and just the fact that he had
like had the foresight to do that
was that's all i needed well all we
needed was more music from kelsey
lucky for us she dropped her fourth
studio album ballerini but
there is a twist kelsey's glitter she's
bold
effervescent her dreams are boundless
she's who i want to be but ballerini
she's emotional vulnerable soft the same
songs
from the same heart just told in a
different way
[Music]
what inspired you to take this on i put
out
kelsey the album march 20th which was
just a really unfortunate
time to be releasing music we had this
big release plan and this big tour that
i was so excited about that we never
even got to announce it just
it all went away someone really close to
me was like
you can't change the circumstances but
you love what you've made
and the best thing you could do is
challenge yourself to fall back in love
with it and so that's what i did and
that's what ballerini was it was me
just going i made kelsey to sound
glittery and commercial and ready to
tour and ready for confetti cannons you
know
and that's just not what this year is
this album ballerini in particular it's
it's really highlighting the songwriter
in me i'm just grateful that i was
challenged to
not move on from something that i really
am so proud of
we love your collaboration with halsey
on the other girl how did that come
about
halsey's my friend and i i appreciate
her so much as an artist
but i also adore her as a human these
two women telling the story of
the angst and darkness and it just made
sense to do it with someone that
i that i love and um and i'm lucky that
she did it with me
are there any other artists that you
want to collaborate in
the country world or maybe outside the
next artist on my
on my like bucket list is carrie and i
think she's an artist that kind of
obviously is like the country
queen but um but she also i think really
transcends
genres as well and is such a big part of
like
my inspiration to be a woman in country
music let's just
manifest it let's speak it into
happening you are speaking to the right
girl i am all about that
brought to you by jamison vitamins here
for your health